ach hey ich hab euch gar nicht bemerkt
ich war gerade dabei mein ganzes geld
sozialen dieses mal wird er sein maul
aufmacht nicht aber damit ist luca und
herzlich willkommen wie heute zu einer
neuen episode tinc-news bei der serie
tik tok user geht es darum dass ich euch
jeden dienstag die besten tipps der
woche präsentieren
und das allerbeste allerdings habe ich
auf meinem 2 kanal hochgeladen also hier
könnt ihr mal drauf klicken und euch das
video anschauen oder nach dem video
unten in die video beschreibung schauen
da ist es ja von der staat mit dem
zweitbesten tag der woche
weil es nicht so cool aber wir machen
einfach direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
[Musik]
das
muss ich leider jetzt schon sagen dass
wirklich die wahrheit uhr in der früh zu
holen
ich würde ihm empfehlen
hatten affen als als haustier okay ich
bin dezent neidisch
platz das bin leider hundertprozentig
auch ich wieder klar
muss das jetzt einfach mal sagen okay
also ich bin auf dem weg zum einkaufen
und man soll ja jetzt solche
gesichtsmasken tragen ich meine versteht
mich nicht falsch ich finde das ist eine
super idee
ja ok weiter geht's ich weiß ich sagt er
wird heute schon zum 47
aber das ist wirklich auch wieder die
wahrheit und die schecks nicht
das ist das genau auf diesen gemälde des
bekannten künstlers sehen ja ein schönes
haus und garten ein schönes auto und
schöne der genaue hinsehen merkt mir es
ist kein gemeldet auch kraß danke dir
dann habe ich das immer falsch
betrachtet
[Musik]
ich brauch glaube ich gar nicht das
sagen was ich jetzt wieder sagen würde
[Musik]
eine maus mit einem koch hut auf und sie
schaut rattern tun
was kommt als nächstes in rund der vier
gewinnspiele haben ich frag mich
wirklich gar nichts mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich frag mich wirklich gar nichts mehr
[Musik]
das ist meine lieben freunde war das
aller aller aller allererste tik tok im
heutigen video wo ich mir wirklich
dachte wow das ist schön das ist cool
das hat eine message ich hoffe das wird
weiterhin bei so einer qualitativ
hochwertigen sachen
[Musik]
ja
es war ja klar aber gut im nächsten tik
tok profi basketballer vielleicht warum
habe ich diese serie mit meinen jungs
chillen oder mit meiner freundin chillen
mit meiner freundin schön cool und
welcher
ok ok musst du musst du musst nicht
kleine lara dir hier abgewinnen alter
mann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hat er gerade
herausgefunden wie man bei online class
das so tun kann als wäre man vom rechter
mann ist es aber gar nicht
das habt ihr nicht das ist interessant
sein wie teuer ist
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt in nächster zukunft
immer irgendwie wahrheit sagen wir jetzt
einfach da muss jetzt nicht mehr sagen
wenn ich das bei meiner mutter gemacht
hätte dann würde ich hier glaube ich
nicht mehr stehen ja nicht für jeden
blick auf dieses feld
ok mal ganz kurz sein video hat 67800
likes dh er will mehr geld auf dem konto
[Musik]
das ist halt echt das coole an tik tok
so man kann zwischendurch auch noch was
lernen
99 das war komplett auf der plattform
aber man kann auch ein bisschen was
lernen
doppel gold to go green steht dir wenn
ich die frau gewesen mehr
ich hätte die ganze wohnung kompletter
will
[Musik]
die sonne
alter extrem krass danke dir für den
hammer live weg also wenn das nächste
mal ein kabel in der kaffeetasse darum
ist ein hammer was du hier alle bruder
das ist ja kein hund mehr du hast ja ein
pferd als haustier
[Musik]
da frage ich mich dann jetzt tatsächlich
gar nichts mehr
victor kubicek baustoff 1000 du hast
eine fernbedienung damit dein klodeckel
o
jetzt habe ich definitiv sehen glauben
die menschheit verloren
ich weiß nicht ob es nur mir gerade so
geht aber irgendwoher kommt mir diese
person ist dass der dings von löwenzahn
er sieht genauso aus wie dieser typ von
löwenzahn ich bin ich länder halt
einfach dein maul dicker okay okay wenn
ich das ding vor meinem fenster gesehen
hätte hätte ich 40.000 liter piste in
meiner hose
[Musik]
irgendwie lerne ich in der heutigen
folge tip top teams sei einfach wieder
wie viel langeweile
manche menschen in der quarantäne gerade
haben
walt disney anfängerin
[Musik]
echt ein bisschen die drei aus meinen
ohren raus geflossen
[Musik]
dann ist die folge endlich vorbei an der
stelle mich heute in dem sektor zu
entwenden freunde weltweit gefahndet hat
das gerne einen daumen hoch oder wie
hier scheinen sich glauben und in die
kommentare wenn er in die nächste folge
tickt auch chinesen dienstag ein kommen
wollte und mein tipp doch was ich heute
hochgeladen habe was sehr sehr aufwendig
war habe ich auf meinem 2 kanal
hochgeladen
da könnt ihr einfach jetzt mal drauf
klicken dann könnt ihr euch das
anschauen es war wirklich eine menge
menge arbeit also mich würd's recht
freuen wenn ihr darauf klicken würde
wir sind echt im schnitt ein bisschen
die tränen gekommen und hier ist ein
smiley wenn ihr darauf klickt und ihm
einen kanal abonnieren falls sie noch
kein abonnent zeit würde ich nicht
empfehlen weil klopapier